Alright, now, part of the reason, we can't just solve these
kinds of problems by solving, a system of linear equations and just
being done with it, the reason we have to do these squares
is because of the presence of errors. The training data that, that
we are given, has errors in it. And it's not that
we're actually modelling, a function, but ,the thing that we're seeing is
the function plus some, you know, some error term on each piece
of data. So, I think, it's reasonable to, to think about where
did these errors come from? So, I don't know,
what do you think ,Charles, why, why is it we're
trying to fit data, that ,has error in it,
can't we just, can't we just have no errors? [LAUGH]
>> I would like to have no errors. Certainly ,my code, has
no errors. [CROSSTALK] well, so let's see where might errors come from.
So, they could come from, sensor error, right? Just ,somehow you're, you're
getting inputs and you're getting outputs and that output's, being read by,
some machine or by a camera or by something and you just, there's just
error in the way that you read the data. Just an error in the sensors.
>> Alright, can you think of other ways. I guess, I
guess ,in this case you're imagining that the data came by
actually measuring something, with the machine. So that, that makes, a
lot of sense. What other ways, can we put together the data?
>> I don't know I could think of a bunch. I mean
the error, well, the errors could come, maliciously. There could be some,
something out there, that is trying to give us bad data.
>> Alright, that seems like a possibility, that, when the
data set was collected, let's say that we're collecting, various,
Oh, maybe if I. Oh, this happens, this happens a
lot. So, so, if you're trying to collect data from
other Computer Science departments and you're trying to put together,
some kind of collection of, you know, how much do you
spend on your. Graduate students ,say,uh, sometimes ,these departments will
actually misrepresent the data and give you give you, things that
are wrong. Because, they don't want to tell you the
truth, because they're afraid of what you are going to do.
>> Yeah, I've noticed that everyone does
that except, for Georgia Tech and Brown University.
>> Yeah, there are highly honest and reputable universities in my experience.
>> Yeah, that's what I feel.
>> well, another time that you can get data, is if somebody, is,
copying stuff down. So, what about sort of the idea of a transcription error.
>> Uh-huh.
>> So we're just, you know, we've
copied everything, but, you know, there's, there's
just some of the, some of the lines that got filled in just got mistyped.
>> Yeah, and you think ,that's different from sensor error?
>> Well, it's, it's maybe a slightly different
kind of sensor error, right? So ,sensor errors
were actually saying there's something physical, that's being
measured and there's just noise in that. Transcription
error, is similar except it's a person. [LAUGH]
>> Mm.
>> Right? The, the there's a little blips in the
person's head and they can do, it can be a
very different kind of error. You can get, like transpositions
of digits, maybe instead of ,um, just you know, noise.
>> Okay, how bout, how bout one more? How about ,uh,
there's really, just noise, in the process. So how about that, that we
took in input X, but there's something else going on in the world, that
we weren't measuring, and so the output
,might depend on other things besides, simply
,the input that we're looking at. So what would be an example of that?
>> So an un-modeled influence, might be, well, if we're.
>> [CROSSTALK] Let's look at the housing data.
>> That's what I, that's what I was thinking
exactly. So ,in the housing data ,we were just
trying to relate, the size of the houses, to the price, but, there's
a lot of other things like change of the houses to the price and
>> Location, location.
>> Location and location, right those are three really good reasons, that
are not in the particular regression,
that we did, that could ,actually influence
the prices. So right, that and, you know, the quality of the
house and who, who built it, and, you know, the colors, the colors.
>> Even, even, even time of day, or what
the interest rates were that morning, versus the, what
people thought they might be the next day. Who knows?
>> Right and so all these different things are
being considered ,in that particular regression, so we're just
kind of imagining ,that it's noise, that it's just
having a, a ,uh, bumpy influence on the whole process.
>> Sure.
>> All right. So, so what I'd like you to do is select ,the ones
that you think actually are important, the
ones that, that, that could actually come up,
when you're using machine learning and regression to solve your problems.